i want to pay tribute to chadwick
boseman
who's taken from us far too early
sir anthony hopkins honors the late
chadwick boseman
in his 2021 oscars speech i want to pay
tribute
to chadwick boseman was taken from us
far too early as you see anthony's
speech
wasn't given during the 2021 oscar
ceremony
it was posted to instagram hours after
his best actor win
for his role in the father the academy
award
for actor goes to anthony hopkins
the father
the academy congratulates anthony
hopkins and accepts
the oscar on his behalf the 83 year old
actor's pr rep confirmed to et
that he was asleep at his home in the uk
when he won
anthony's rep says he called the actor
at 4 am to share the good news and says
he was
so happy and surprised and filled with
gratitude
not long after anthony took to instagram
to reflect on his big win
and second academy award
good morning well here i am in my
homeland in wales
and at 83 years of age i did not expect
to get this award i really didn't and
very grateful to the academy and thank
you
and i want to pay tribute to chadwick
boseman
who's taking from us far too early
and again thank you all very much
i really did not expect this so
i feel very privileged to know it thank
you
anthony was nominated in the same
category as the late chadwick boseman
who died in august after battling colon
cancer
after winning the golden globe and the
sag award fans thought chadwick was
poised to nab a posthumous oscar
as well but when joaquin phoenix
announced anthony as the winner
many took to social media to share their
thoughts and reactions
anthony wasn't the only one to pay
tribute to chadwick on hollywood's
biggest night
angela bassett who played chadwick's
on-screen mom
in black panther introduced the knights
in memoriam montage which of course
featured the late actor
[Music]
and when e.t spoke with angela over
video chat after the show
she opened up about why the moment felt
so significant
you introduced the immemorium and the
chadwick was in that
did it make it different because you had
such a connection just being a big deal
where
of course a great love and a great
artist a great
you know a great man just made this
transition and the world just
warned him and loved himself
along with so many others but to see
chadwick
it was as if there were even more so
of a you know of a wake for me
to to speak what it was so it was an
honor for me
um to be a part of this ceremony and
especially given them
the more even though chadwick didn't win
he's still number one in your heart
correct he's number one in my heart
yes